deuxième photo ah bon d'archaos passera
c'est joey starr on se rejoint là dessus
on n'est pas à terre comme des oufs sur
le gars il t'a des critiques et on note
notamment lors de la mort de johnny
n'est ni encore une nouvelle tragique
pour la culture française aujourd'hui on
aurait retrouvé maître gims eux bien
vivant chez lui il avait tenté aussi une
autre blague qu'elle est l'appareil qui
mesurent la musique de m de merde le
maître gims voilà c'est même pas savoir
en anglais c'est pas ça va tu mon nom
voilà donc toi tu t'en fous raconte même
pas près voilà c'est bon c'est joey il à
eelv à 66 parcours il a beaucoup de
chance ah oui c'est un artiste c'est un
grand artiste non plus penser c'est un
grand j'aime beaucoup aussi j'aime
beaucoup le fait c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup par un super mec